you do not have to achieve transcendence
or self-understanding through tradition
which means reading all these horrible
books
memorizing all these sanskrit terms
these excruciating exercises and you
know it
no there is a way to do it
so then that issue is settled can it be
done that issue is settled and the issue
becomes do i want to do it now that i
know the transcendence is possible where
does it stand in relationship to my
ordinary life we were talking last night
about how
what psilocyman really does
is it makes possible
the realization of what is probably a
strong fantasy of all of us
which is to be
an enlightened human being or a very
advanced kind of spiritual being
but
in the context of the present world you
sort of have to realize that an advanced
spiritual being in this world
is someone who
chops wood and draws water
and
ordinary people occasionally glimpse
them through the drifting mist and fog
and say oh so he's still alive up there
on the mountain we haven't seen him for
10 years 20 years he must still be up
there
i don't know if it's possible to be a
buddha and a cpa at the same time i
rather doubt it
when we had the experiences at la
terraria in 1971
one of the things i was most grateful
for was that the mushroom seemed to have
tricked us almost to coming so far out
into the wilderness that we could not
get out there was no emergency number to
call
we had to deal with it on its own terms
and i think that's
really what you have to do and in a
small way that's why when i say to
people you know you take it alone in the
darkness you have to grapple with it on
its own terms
and it isn't frightening but it is uh
profound and alien and other
and it's this alien otherness which has
actually been tugging at us from the
very beginning to a very large degree we
are
this alien thing and in fact some people
say
entirely in other words that there is no
extraterrestrial there is only
adequations of the otherness in human
beings
but
operationally it doesn't really matter
because the otherness is so complete
that we have to reach for the metaphor
of extraterrestrials
the same way that a 14th century person
would have had to believe that they were
encountering a manifestation of the
immaculate conception or something like
that we will we always have control
languages but when you're in the grip of
the
full psychedelic experience you see your
control languages just melting away
you finally see you know
is it a flying saucer is it the
sacrament of the vedas it seems to be
all these things and more it seems in
fact to defy
the human wish to define it
and it became then you realize it's it's
a mystery a mystery is not an unsolved
problem a mystery is not a
describable but undescribed topology a
mystery is something that
we cannot encompass
it was uh jbs haldane who said the world
may not only be stranger than we suppose
it may be stranger than we can suppose
and i would say for sure it is stranger
than we can suppose and that's no reason
to stop supposing
because
supposing carried on at the highest
level gives us the best maps of reality
that we have we should just not assume
that we have it nailed down language is
very tricky the psychedelic experience
can become almost anything that one says
it is
originally i think what shamanism was
was a kind of heightened intuition
for instance
weather prophecy
and diagnosing and treating of disease
especially treating of disease by the
use of hands on the body and also the
use of plants in the immediate
environment this is an ability to
respond to intuition you know in the
middle ages there was what was called
the doctrine of signatures which was
that everything by its physical
appearance
was conveying a message about what it
was good for
well that's sort of a
crude way of saying
that
rupert's sheldrick's morphogenetic field
is right on the surface of every object
you just need to sensitize yourself to
it and pull it out
there are many forms of telepathy
that are possible i think using
psychedelics direct mind to mind
transfer
both people contemplating the same
the same modality of hallucination
but a very interesting form of telepathy
which is not strictly speaking telepathy
at all because there's no carrier wave
is an ability to so shed your
inhibitions about other people
that you can automatically adapt their
adopt their point of view
and they don't even realize what is
happening and you just sit in front of
someone and say
you know it's a way of clearing yourself
and then you say i know
what you're into i know what you want
and i know it because i can clearly
perceive what i want and i have just
lost the illusion that we're different
and
this is an immense kind of empathetic
understanding that was achieved
you know not through the generation of a
strange brainwave but through a shift in
assumptions and it's this shifting of
assumptions very gradually that will
allow us to create a
language new languages to
assimilate these things and this has
been happening steadily this is i think
what human history is it's a very
extended psychedelic trip
it is what you see in two and a half
hours is essentially what has gone on
been thought almost gone on hoped for
and been supposed over the last hundred
thousand years
and you see it all
in a uh in a kind of super accelerated
overview and that's why it has
this very
significant feeling
of resonating with you but why it is so
difficult to say anything about it or to
english it because we're not used to
that kind of perspective
so i think you know the great uh the
final failure of education in this
country has been the de-emphasis of
history
and the production of
generations of people who are total
amnesiacs
they don't know what was going on in the
14th century or the 8th century bc
so essentially they don't know who they
are
because that is who you are the
psychedelic point of view of a person is
to see a person as just a moving wave
front of genetic expression that is
present in the here and now and and go
extends backward into time through the
ancestors
there's something which is called the
dao of the ancestors which is simply for
each one of us
the best way to do things the best way
to pick up a pencil the best way to
take a drink and this is how
the people who stand behind you have
always done it
and so when you do it that way it isn't
like you doing it at all it's as though
all of those people act to do it the
morphogenetic field for that activity is
so strong
i first
noticed this when i had it took a course
in shamanism and one of the little
projects that they wanted us to do was
to chip flint
and to make arrow points which i had
never done and when i sat down and
started to do it 30 seconds into it i
realized you know my god this is what
people are made for this is what they've
been doing for the past three hundred
thousand three million years less five
thousand everything else keyboard
punching sculpting of madonnas mummy
making cathedral building glyph carving
that's all peanuts compared to the
amount of time we've been shipping stone
and you feel it in your hands you have a
memory of how to do this and we may have
many memories of how to do many things
if we will but open ourselves up we
cannot go into the future with the
luxury of an unconscious the h-bomb
ensures this and so you see in a very
weird way
the h-bomb is
is a
catalyst for evolutionary advance it's
the final catalyst for evolutionary
advance it's like the breaking of the
water
in a birth once this happens there's no
going back
once you have hydrogen fusion you
probably have a hundred years maximum to
figure it out or you will be
extinct but it is not necessarily lethal
its purpose is not to destroy us its
purpose is to sober us up and push us
forward to the next level
the energy release
the fascination with energy release that
we've been exploring for the past
several thousand years culminates in
you know hallucinogenic drugs and
massive release of energy on the atomic
level and we need to use these things to
to push ourselves forward if it wasn't
for the sobering effect of the presence
of hydrogen bombs all over the planet
i'm not sure that the cultural debate on
transformation would be taking place at
all do you think it's a coincidence that
hoffman took lsd in 1942
at the same time they were building the
first atomic bomb
no i don't think there are coincidences
i think all this stuff is part of the
plan it's all led in
and i i said
oh i don't know several years ago at
essel and i said what mushroom is it
that grows at the end of human history
is it the mushroom of
oppenheimer and teller or is it the
mushroom of hoffman and wasan
because it's definitely about
transformation and release of energy
into thanatos or eros and these two
possibilities
loom directly in front of us and i think
as i've heard john say the universe
loves you ruthlessly it will watch and
let you make this decision let us make
this decision
and
we can't know
how rare a thing humanness is
we can't know how much hangs in the
balance if we
if we blow it certainly we have uh only
the vagus intimations that anything like
what we have achieved has been achieved
anywhere else
i think you know the greatest glory of
god is probably an act of human
understanding
there's nothing that transcends the
potential power of that because somehow
the fate of god
is tied up in the human fate i mean a
god without human beings is a
is a fairly neutral kind of concept we
are as i said the catalytic agents of
the cosmic drama
and
i don't know to what degree
we are
monkeys
to what degree consciousness is a thing
alien to the monkeys and using primate
organization
simply as a foundation
for itself
for instance you know in the in the 19th
century the great challenge to people's
conception of what is human
was the notion that we were descended
from the apes the sin of darwin and
people just
were appalled and could not write that
into their script i think the the great
challenge in the 20th century that is
going to force people to rethink what is
humanness is going to be the perfection
of thinking machines this will be the
final
humiliation
of our privileged place in the cosmos
and yet you know we've gotten used to
the idea that we're descended from
primates and i think we can get used to
the idea that we can produce thinking
machines it will just be said after all
they wouldn't be here if we hadn't made
them
so
but but that kind of thing raises the
question as to what is consciousness and
to what degree is it dependent on
organic or cybernetic organization can
we go off
into the private idahos of our own heads
is that what history is leading us
toward is that what heaven is
that heaven is the realization of a
historical state that is ruled over by
the physics of the imagination rather
than the
the inert physics of the of the not of
the creation of the demo urge the the
physics of the inert material universe
i think probably it is you know plato
said if god didn't exist man would
invent
it him her
if paradise doesn't exist we will
probably create it and hell as well
certainly history is a series of
pendulum shifts from heavens to hells
always with the idea that one justifies
the other but in our heads
we contact these realities that are not
the privilege of yogans or mystics or
people who spend years and years in
monasteries they're the privilege of any
human being courageous enough to seek
them
and
i think that
is a tremendous carrot to historical
evolution it means that each one of us
is an agent of this thing you don't have
to think of yourself as a cog in a large
machine in fact that whole notion of
cogs and machines
can give way to the notion of
a
solid state set of equally potentiated
oscillators each one of which may send
out a signal that the other oscillators
will fall into resonance with
and
it has to do with the creation of a
commonality of language
and a common understanding about these
things and an effort to talk ever more
clearly about the content of the
experience without referencing it back
to everything that has been tabooed
without thinking of it as you know the
province of mystics or the province of
psychopathy it is in fact the unclaimed
part of ourselves in the same way that
uh
you know sexuality has been claimed as a
part of ourselves i mean there have been
very few eras in human history where
sexuality was fully explored and
realized and
where this did happen they tended to be
ancillary to the main forward thrust of
historical civilization it's only since
freud really that a global civilization
cognizant of sexuality has emerged
following upon that and maybe even
consequent upon that is realizing that
the most erotic
organ of the body is the mind
and
coupling that with the concept of
psychedelic drugs lays open the
possibility for a truly humane society
based uh essentially on euros
and
this
this is the millennium that everyone is
talking about you know this is the
possibility of actually shedding
the freight
of the historical experience and
existing in a kind of uh elysium of
consciousness that is the fruits
of having
come through the crisis in the biosphere
that the emergence of consciousness
represents
because
consciousness will generate ideas
and these ideas
will and are carrying us off the planet
out into space deeper into ourselves
deeper into interphase with cybernetic
matrices
deeper
into an understanding of the mechanics
of the planet and our place in it
and
all of the cultural concerns of the last
500 years are essentially coming to a
culmination
and will be replaced we hope
with
a different set of considerations
i remember when i was a child i often
heard the saying if wishes were horses
beggars would ride
and i think the politics of the
millennium are all tied up in that
we must make wishes horses so that
beggars do ride and then every beggar
will have a horse
and
society will be much better off for it
i see human history as a psychedelic
experience that is accessible to
everyone if you study it if you look
back through it if you get so you can
feel it then it's all there you know all
those people
all that blood all that treasure all
those hopes and love affairs and
betrayals and disappointments
are somehow
for us
were for us
and these people are living in us
in the expectation of our completing
this project so long
in the making in other words of our
completing the tale
and
silly simon shows you that movie it
shows you history i mean when i take it
i say i invoke it and i say you know
show the old things show the elder
possibilities and it always
carries me back you know to this place
the caspian sea nine to fifteen thousand
years ago
the rugs the weaving the horse hair the
polished brass
the
fermented mare's milk all of this stuff
that's where it began it's when these
psychedelic using tribes encountered
the mountain ranges of central asia that
presented such a barrier
that the pressure
out of that contact i think emerged
consciousness or or consciousness
finally took hold like a flame on the
human species and has not relinquished
its uh its presence ever since
and yet you know the mushroom says
this is an opportunity it will not last
forever if consciousness is not
um
transformed again and again into higher
and higher states of itself
it can fall victim to the lower
darwinian mechanics that operate on the
planet in other words we can be found to
be not
a glorious
exemplification of the laws of the
universe but a
lethal and destructive force and
in that case we will be eliminated and
the planet will return to the gentle
cycle of the seasons and the millennia
that were what life on this planet was
until a million years ago
we are some kind of grand roll of the
dice
some kind of
almost god's vision of his own salvation
through the notion of human beings
and
the way in which these insights are
going to be recovered is through
psychedelics not through ideology
because ideology is too confining
somebody always wants to tell you how
you should be
and
only direct experience of the mystery is
really valid this is why we need to
create a shamanic class of people who
are pointing
[Music]
out toward the future with a knowledge
of the past
and
and bringing it into being
[Music]
you